hello there reject nation we're going to
watch loki
episode 1 today very excited since all
the trailers came out
loki has easily been my most anticipated
series
of them all john and i will alternate
between the spider-man chair maybe
it looks better on him right now so come
over there yeah it's good thanks man
it's good it's good
already i'm flattered that's good maybe
one day we'll get two
marble cheers i don't know if it's
possible though
we're dragging the center out john guys
hit that like button if you end up
enjoying our reaction or if you just
want to be nice
hit it right now also subscribe click
that notification bell to get notified
when our next reaction for loki is up as
always full length watch along where you
sync up with the time code is over it's
all patreon page and over there we got
full length reaction watch alongs and
reaction highlights for
many shows these thumbnails flashing on
screen
as per real reject selective chosen
advertisement for said paige
are only a few of the shows lastly
pratham gendal thank you so much for
editing these for us buddy you're a hard
worker
you slave away for us that's right and
we pay you
pennies we own you
go fetch the pittance to me
that's how we treat anyone we work
everyone loves working with us
they do anyways
avengers adventures
assembled all the way down coordinate
search and rescue on my way down to
coordinate search and rescue
yes stop stop
slice
[Music]
here we go so excited
i'm so deliciously excited right now
i feel your excitement i'm ready for
mischief
we've got the green tint yeah should
have worn my green jacket green and gold
great shot look like a painting yeah
it's probably a digital map painting
i am loki
never mind variant identified
i beg your partner variant now
get out of my way
it's like the neo agent smith punch dave
whoa speed
but feeling all that pain in real time
oh how cool i didn't realize that was
happening
it was like what a weird drawn out slow
motion to linger on
oh wait reset the timeline
reset the timeline
none of this will affect phases two or
three
this loki's just having a hell of a day
just lost to the avengers and
he has one break taken right away from
him
thanos is gonna be pissed
[Music]
yeah that's what i'm talking about
steamy hiddleston
get that marble body shot right away oh
isn't it outfit i don't need
i mean you should read it through just
in case
please confirm to your knowledge that
you are not a fully robotic being
do a lot of people not know if they're
robots thank you for your confirmation
if i was a robot and i didn't know it
what's that your temporal aura what's
that please through the door
it's like an angry cat he's so annoying
tom nelson's ripped that's right he's
nicely toned and check this out
whoa yeah
but then the all-knowing timekeepers
emerged
cool to a single timeline
maybe you started an uprising or were
just late for work
nexus nexus
wow wow god
incredible workers i love this animation
for
all time
i'm really opening up the multiverse
here yeah with classic
animation i tried to ask that guy for a
ticket would you
raising your voice with me buckethead
the threat just got real oh yeah loki
you know
this feels like uh wow look at those
credits yeah
feels like when you wanted those marvel
one shots to get expanded into something
yeah yeah you know wow i love all the
throwback vibes with their uh
their animation style absolutely so when
they arrived
somebody got the jump on them you think
hawkeye
mephisto is finally here
oh
really drawing attention to it don't
worry that devil's afraid of us
we're gonna take care of him
i'm not gonna hop up
somewhere eric voss is about to explode
sir there's something you'll want to see
moebius is so nice
i know he saved the cat
came into possession of the tesseract
because they traveled through time
no doubt in a last-ditch effort to stave
off my ascent
to god king
i think season 3 so that's hilarious
what they did was supposed to happen you
escaping
was not okay all right all right
guilty
of this
left it's not your story mr laughs and
it never was
you have no idea the nature of the
universe
i thought there was no magic here where
is it
[Music]
it's all science it's right and and
cosmic energy i imagine
that is beautiful time passes
differently here in the tva
what does that mean you'll catch up
all the time he's been saying what yeah
every single step of the way
trust is for children and dogs there's
only one person you can trust
yourself i like it loki's gonna learn to
trust
uh oh i live within whatever path i
choose sure you do okay come at us
so unaffected by it well they just all
cast off free will
come on sit down let's get
into this he's clearly your only friend
man don't try to kill him
come on play along and get some info at
least
he's your only friend looks good kill
what do you want from me you should see
him without a shirt on oh
if pecks could kill there's a fork in
every road
yet the wrong path always taken
big metaphor guy i love it makes you
sound super smart
no okay okay
oh man oh wilson's sincerity is perfect
for this
it's perfect donald's killing a man
that's how it is
that's funny for someone born to rule
you sure do lose a lot might even say
it's in your nature
i know what i am a murderer a liberator
oh damn the db cooper one okay cool
i love how loki just can't look at his
actions i know he does feel shame
exactly what he's talking about he
better be ready
thor helped out with this i guess you
really wanted some american money
whoa is this a different camera
different yeah aspect it looks like
i can't believe you were db cooper
come on and i lost a bat to thor
where was the tv uh let's get back to
escapes
a little cycle battle what is it that
you think that you're really
enough this table
i was just standing up to make a point
i'm sorry go ahead my baby's meaningful
now we're gonna
stay seated i'll do what i want to do
what exactly is it
you hadn't picked up the tesseract you
would have been taken to a cell on
asgard
oh he's about to learn time to learn
see what else you did you were born to
cause pain
and suffering and death that's how it is
that's how it was
that's how it will be oh man also that
others
can achieve their best versions of
themselves
wow whoa what a
confrontation you gotta make with
yourself
yeah grappling with your cosmic place
it's something terrible
we have a situation there's always a
situation
don't go anywhere i love this self-aware
script
absolutely it's got like
a cheeky twilight zoniness hey loki i
think we can finish up tomorrow and just
pick it up
where have you gone
mischief managed
oh he took it
[Music]
i don't mean this in any hyperbolic
manner the show is already
shaped up to exactly what i wanted it to
be
let's see how the whole thing goes this
is amazing give me the tesseract
i'll gut you like a fish casey what's a
fish but what difference does it make i
want to know exactly what i'm being
threatened with before i comply
[Laughter]
it's just right to desk
is it bigger on the inside oh wow
whoa
how do you have these oh we actually got
a lot of those
some of the guys use them as
paperweights some of them
oh no oh god no
take him loki just take a handful
get a scoop in a bag
it says it's it's like
identity crisis it's like a great
existential
outlet love it so good
i don't even want this anymore man i
ever wanted matters
is this the greatest power in the
universe
oh
[Music]
oh that's crazy he's realizing the power
of the tva doesn't even care about his
stones i love you my sons
remember this place
[Applause]
oh but you're skipping on all the funny
parts of that
that one
yeah man you've had a lot of great times
two funny moments in that one
oh he did what he did i put my faith in
who
i trusted you
oh what to say i couldn't catch it
end of fire
[Music]
oh oh oh
no
nice
oh
stop sit
stop it
and this guy kept saying he was going to
turn me
always watching
[Music]
i don't enjoy hurting people
explain that to me because it's part of
the illusion
to inspire fear whoa is he being sincere
damn mommy
the variant we're hunting is you
i think you're fun
come on just confirm it's lady loki
[Laughter]
[Music]
the music is
phenomenal on point
[Music]
oh
great nice
can't wait to watch a new rock stars
video now
yeah bring on the easter eggs i'm sure
there's plenty in just these credits
alone
that devil's afraid of us one division
didn't put such a fear in predicting
mephisto
yeah we got to find out if that wasn't
wonderful she'd be like that's a hundred
per thousand percent
yeah now we have to start coming up with
theories of what else that could mean
that's
not it please if you're watching made
this far
comment all the easter eggs and stuff
that you noticed this show is one where
i'm like i bet there's a ton just
lurking
and so many frames yeah so many cheeky
details
they shoot some of this on film i wonder
because of some of the uh
you know style variation i could see it
and i like that the title is very
reminiscent of the one of the ads but
not quite the same
no it looks like uh like an old-school
projection work guy
feels like eight millimeter or something
yeah like an old school projection mixed
with like a bunch of old type sets
yeah there's kind of that like booming
menacing uh
yeah like sci-fi 80s music yeah that
like percolating foreboding scene
yeah i love it love it all right let's
talk about it
i have thoughts on the episode papa you
know i feel like uh
i'm waiting okay i'm waiting for when
marvel knew they had to be strong with
all their pilots
they knew it yes they knew it yeah and
and then uh i'm just like
okay i am getting to the po room like i
don't want to just keep sounding like a
broken record
whatever i watch a flat pilot please
marvel can you
lob us a soft ball to criticize but damn
that was
um that was literally everything i
wanted it to be for a first episode and
even a little more so you know i thought
it might have had a little bit more
from the trailers i thought the rhythm
and the pacing might have been
like a little bit more like a punch to
it a little bit more upbeat
but i i love how this
still while intro did a lot here that
you got to commend the show for
they introduced the tva expanded upon
the whole multiverse thing
reintroduced you back into the whole
thing with who like who loki is like
you god i thought they did a really
great job too
of like audiences who haven't really
been following a lot of the behind the
scenes or details on all these things
because that way they can be like okay i
know exactly what's going on i know who
loki is
and introducing mobius to setup with the
villain but then also keeping it a
character piece
about loki as well and having this
almost
uh tragic quality to him like
like this version of loki by this point
he's a pretty messed up guy he's
murdered a lot
of people and he's done a lot of really
messed up things
and yet by that point where he's uh
talking with moebius you know i had to
question because we've seen him do so
many gleeful types of
you know he's got a mischief and he's
murdered a lot of people and he just
tried taking over earth and
murdered a lot of people like like just
yesterday according to this
right so um it feels
it did such a good job at hooking you
into the pathos of
of it with the writing the music the
direction and of course tom hiddleston's
uh like brilliant performance here
because
like the music i kept with the music it
was sort of
alternating between really cool like as
we were talking about that booming
percolating like uh sci-fi synth
mixed with occasionally when it was
going for more of its tragic undertones
this
uh this almost almost like you're
watching a norse mythology character
like it had this fantasy
quality to it yeah you know you can
imagine
sort of like uh hopping into like a god
of war fantasy game of thrones world
with the kind of music they had because
it is a norse mythology character still
so they were blending both of those both
of those together
yeah yeah i thought this was uh
i thought this was great i love the tone
and the pacing of it the atmosphere of
being in the tva how it took its time
so much yeah and yet said it's just
yeah just fired on all cylinders for me
this was uh
i'll find something bad to talk about
when you only
have something to criticize yeah but no
i mean
it was like super duper enthralling
because yeah i mean you have like a
two-sided debate going on of loki
like coming to terms at all with his
place in the universe the tva
even being open to mobius's you know
advances of at least you know let's work
together or something and then also yeah
the classic sort of i see some potential
in this guy and we got to find a way to
kind of mold him into our agenda but
yeah i mean as a it has that perfect
sort of twilight zone
quality where you do have the excitement
of like oh man
it really does feel like even though you
know the first episode we're only just
being introduced to this but it has that
sort of eerie wonder that like a
twilight zone has
to me where it's like yeah you're
peering into the greater mechanics of
how the universe works and that stuff is
awe-inspiring but it's also kind of
scary
and and i loved yeah watching the arc of
loki over this episode and also i think
it's really interesting
to pull him out of the timeline where
it's like we have so much more context
for his life but he only knows up until
that point where they apprehended him
at avengers tower stark tower um and so
yeah having him then
confront the actions up into this point
but then
seeing what we've already seen play out
i thought made for a very interesting
both you know like a cool sci-fi thing
but also yeah a great way to deconstruct
the character at the outset to kind of
both
recontextualize him so that we can have
him be the protagonist of this show
without us sitting around going didn't
you kill lots of people and inflict pain
and torture yeah like they'd yeah dive
right into it and i feel like that
really helps bolster all the other cool
fun stuff you know
well it has the benefit of
the audience having seen thor the dark
world or ragnarok and having been on the
journey
and then right up to his death in
avengers infinity war
having the audience witness the journey
of loki going from bad
into a good guy for them yeah that's a
good guy
yeah yeah pretty good sacrifice he was
he was trying to do
right to his final moments he was trying
to do the right thing and then by and
with the way ragnarok ended he
he was alongside his brother you know so
he did arc
and so you do know that there's a good
person
in him yeah right potential is there
always like we've always known that
about loki that he's a tragic character
uh but we were it's not difficult to
sell you
on it yeah even with this version
because we know where he's been and then
even him getting these emotional
responses
to witnessing the the the highlights
the most emotional just jumping around
time just
the most traumatic moments of your life
i guess if i could criticize something
it's
the incredible nitpicking quality of i
love how this just
skips right to like just the key
emotional beats he needs to see
yeah you know each of the memories has
like points on the timeline has a tag of
like oh here's a heartbreaking one
here's a tragic one here's a really
guilt-inspiring one yeah here's one to
make you feel all right though but your
dad's dead i bet you didn't know that
there's yeah it doesn't just hop to like
any of the gladiator battles
yeah yeah or any of the triumph cards or
anything like that it doesn't do any of
these like
random scenes just like perfectly skips
too i don't know if mobius headed up
that way
yeah like no i need these specific
scenes
just skip right to the mirror into his
soul it's not something i thought of
at all uh i uh but yeah you guys looking
back
that's such a that's that's just me that
that's just me looking forward to
picking him for fun
that's not a real problem i got what my
my favorite stuff in here i'm a sucker
for a good philosophical debate
have you heard of that wooden ship or
whatever that was
theseus yeah is this loki the same loki
if all the memories and experiences are
replaced off the original loki
um but the conversation that he's having
with
uh uh owen wilson mobius that was
something i said in one of the
the reactions that it might have been
when they showed us the elevator scene
or are you with me in that video i don't
remember i don't think you were with me
in that
i know i was one of them i know that
we've reacted to at least one loki trail
i feel like they were in the elevator
but i'm not sure but that was one thing
i i remember
pointing out that i was looking forward
to out of this show
that i didn't feel like a lot of people
were talking about was just good acting
scene work just good scene work between
two great actors
and you know like for
like a solid like 10 to 15 minutes of
this it's
it's mainly loki and mobius feeling each
other out and
learning to uh develop some type of
relationship
with each other like i love when he
springs him out of there
and then how sincere moebius
seems like i don't feel like he has this
i mean he has a hidden agenda to get to
use him to help hunt down the
uh the um lady loki it's going to be
lady louie all right
what's what's the word the variance yeah
uh deviant is a different part of the
marvel cinematic yeah yeah
uh variant to so yeah he's got that
but in that whole philosophical
conversation of where
it's like a philosophical one it's a
psychological provoking like probing at
you one basically
mobius is just trying to use his tactics
to be able to break down
the wall and get to the vulnerable side
in him
and it's such a well done scene or you
can feel like
mobius is sincere and stuff of like no
i'm a fan
like i admire you yeah and no i'm no
when i say these words about you i'm not
saying it in a way to mock you
like the way how loki keeps reacting
defensively like
from a psychological standpoint this
conversation in this really fantastical
weird ass world
feels very true to human emotions
yeah absolutely and the suspicion from
loki the entire time yeah
yeah it's great it's great scene working
and yeah he's so good owen wilson he's
perfect
absolutely like they're so great at just
listening to each other and his energy
his
owen wilson energy like really does suit
the scenes well because
it's like he leaves the ball of emotion
oh and loki's
court just fire off every possible
response to this probing and it's
bringing him further out just with how
chill mobius is
but i yeah i i think that's really
beautifully done
throughout the episode is the way that
you know i feel like i've heard
complaints in the past about you know
undercutting god level characters with
certain
you know mumbo jumbo or whatever and so
to see loki in this position of
powerlessness but
also then watching him cycle through all
the emotions until he finally comes back
to
you know really what's at the core it
was like
something i wasn't expecting it's like i
wanted a deconstruction and you know
probing at the character but
yeah it really felt like a natural array
of emotions
that have to be sort of cleared and let
go before he can finally resign
to accepting the reality of the
situation and i love how throughout he's
he's constantly sort of at odds with
just the very concept he's belittling
the concept of the time variance
authority
and dismissing it in various ways trying
to come to an
answer until finally he just has to
surrender to its
awe-inspiring weird power to make him
feel tiny in the universe again you know
that was such a such a great moment when
he discovers the stones
yes and he's like he's just got
multiples and you do nothing with them
and
he's about to take one and then he's he
can't do it yeah you're like
i can't it's not even worth it yeah it's
it
it like this is the greatest power and
it's like that part of you is going
like my mind starts going is loki
playing an act to it but we had these
times where we were alone with him and
he's watching the footage of like where
his timeline would have went
and he seems i mean he's like crying and
stuff and he's by himself that's not for
anyone he's
by himself so the one part of my brain
is going there
what if he's just trying to do some
mischievous act to take over the tv8
as much as i want loki to be good like
at the same time it would be
bad yeah that's i mean it's cool that
you have a character where you could
literally have him go any direction as
long as you don't ham fist
any of it or force it but you can
naturally see
it go in any conclusion where he arcs
into oh he's a good version of loki
or he does just like oh man he was doing
his mastermind [ __ ]
yeah because yeah this show brought it
back to the core of when loki was first
introduced this
guy who's surrounded by greatness is a
god
but he feels like no one really loves
him no one really respects him then he's
just
trying he's trying like this all comes
from feeling like a broken child
right like going back to like the first
couple thor movies especially the first
one
that's where this all comes from and
then
he has this whole thing where he's
learning that like the universe doesn't
even
like him the universe the universe it's
cosmically written that you are this guy
that you are meant to be just
essentially a fuck-up
so that way you can elevate other people
to greatness
and which is hard yeah it's
heart-wrenching
to anybody to find that out is like oh
my gosh
like you're designed to be this way so
then it goes back to the
the debates that are like kind of
brought up in my favorite sci-fi film
the matrix
of you know what is choice and what is
destiny
you know and and does you making the
choice to do something different is that
part of the destiny but i guess it's not
because i'm a variant
but maybe me being a variant is part of
the that's you know what i mean
like where is no the cosmic order are
variants allowed for and is someone just
not telling me
yes exactly so i think it just raises a
whole lot of great questions yeah
and um it really committed to the debate
quality too i
i they didn't half-ass it it didn't
leave me going
ah come on show why'd you stop yeah like
they they
lived in it they relished in it yeah
yeah yeah absolutely and again like for
as big and fun as tom hiddleston is to
watch it also makes for a great cipher
experience
for us too and and ah the animation
sequences i just i love
i love how like retro a lot of the stuff
i think that's also oh that's the word
i think that's why the twilight zone
like obviously you know anything that's
got this sort of strange sci-fi but
slightly foreboding twist is gonna get
like into the twilight zone but i think
all those flourishes of yeah like this
art deco and even
like 70s retro looking stuff like all
throughout
the architecture of the time variance
authority and the animated sequence like
it really does suspend it in this other
sort of
strange yeah outside of the timeline
sense of time
you know it really makes this weird
ethereal sci-fi
quality yeah the animation on that was
so fun
yeah it's like watching like uh like
yeah like the old school cartoons yeah
yeah
and um he has a cartoon network but then
goes even earlier than that like
yeah it's like i don't want to name the
wrong animator but it's that error of
like you know he's like chuck jones and
like those yeah
wrong defined lines and noses yeah like
those pastel backgrounds and stuff and
and for the most part a lot of that
looked off that like missed minutes a
couple times
i was like that's that's a cg animated
thing but you know there's a lot that
looked
authentic and i love when marvel throws
down on that stuff yeah i was like when
they started like bringing newspaper
comics to life in a way you know
that vibe um
yeah i'm really endeared to it yeah
really touched
and touched by it if anything like if
anything the one thing that didn't
really the the only thing that seemed
like it
weirdly wasn't necessary it was the tv
cooper part
yeah it's just a highlight from the reel
it's just a fun
part you know like it was in the trailer
and it's in it
when you watch it in the trailer it's
kind of making you wonder
like okay is it part of the missions
that the tva wants him to do
is that like one of them where he does
the db cooper thing that's what it
looked like and then you hear
oh this is just just something he did
like literally that's the most marvel
moment to me out of this of just it's a
fun
moment yeah really necessarily because
we know loki will do stuff
yeah we're not gonna watch an episode
where he steps into the shoes of db
cooper for some ulterior tva
related operations right that's just
kind of a neat moment that they could
throw in the trailer like it's fun it's
enjoyable it's not ultimately necessary
to the plot here
i mean but it's fun yeah and it makes i
don't expect them to do it but part of
me
wishes that it harkens to like a motif
where like every episode we'll see like
one random past
loki adventure where he's actually some
actual world mystery that never got
solved like maybe yeah he was the one
who killed jimmy hoffa i don't know you
know like maybe they'll do that like
each time or something
and if they do that it'll feel better
justified yeah yeah it's like then if
it's a running gag
you know because i don't know how if
they're all going to be this long but
you know that's something you could
pepper in and make a fun
uh you know joke out of or something
yeah it's
and what marvel has done again is
succeed in making their three shows feel
very different
absolutely yeah yeah totally different
tonally and
and in context and consequence and how
it relates to the overall mca
they've all so far and this is only the
first one but they all feel like very
important to the mcu but on
totally different scales yes you know
well this is the show that's directly
doing the whole
this is the one that's starting with the
multiverse tying directly into the
stream i mean one division does and
but loki is the one that seems like it's
actually going to be
dealing with alternate timelines
the multiverse chaos and then
having to hunt down another version of
himself yeah um there you go
multiverse spider-man let's do it well
that's also even too like like
he's found out all this stuff about his
own life but then i'll think of all the
other things variants could reveal about
him
too as a character like that's another
exciting thing for the future i think
oh yeah not only with you know who we
assume is
is lady loki but any other loki variants
we might see you know and then the way
they explained the timeline too was
uh like the one strand of alternate
timelines yeah
fascinating stuff then they completely
were like no the avengers supposed to do
that that was all supposed to happen
yeah they were they got us not going
back and regular special
time travel uh uh you know hall pass
yeah for some reason they do you can
mess with the timeline cap can go live
in the past
whatever yeah they've earned it they're
the avengers
no not you power's the bee man they're
big fans it's kind of crazy how all that
connect
but but they do even they they do
even address that to a certain extent of
it's a different hole you can go down in
the way how
you know when it comes to time travel
rules there's always like
these doors that open where you're like
uh let's not go there you know that's
the way it
constantly goes i don't think too hard
yeah nothing's too hard because you can
find a bunch of
weird plot holes there and then here
this opens up a different one
again harking you back to the themes of
choice and destiny of
loki's even saying like why is it okay
that i did that
i think that's the db cooper thing right
yeah like why is it okay that i did that
but it's not okay that i'm here now yeah
this random
like little thing i did that seems
completely frivolous to the overall
scope of time i guess they use the db
cooper thing to justify the the
the again the questioning and the debate
of it and the randomness of it all
yeah it's like yeah why can cap go back
and be like live with peggy and all that
all that
i'll deal with the idea of all the also
the [ __ ] with like the different
you know everything that happened in
infinity war and again right yeah like
what do we need to do
why is that allowed yeah yeah we can't
he loki can't be here yeah exactly it's
interesting it's really interesting
stuff
um so
let's get into it oh and the last thing
too it's like i thought they might i
like how the tva guards and stuff
actually seemed uh competent like that
absolutely they were
highly they weren't just like their
muscle but the the effects that they do
on them
are are really cool and like the
different types of gadgets and gizmos
and the
like the rules of when he's thrust it in
here in the beginning are so fun but
yeah like the the rewind oh yeah that
like time yeah whatever
weird time looper thing they get to
transport you through
space every time yeah that was cool and
yeah i mean i like the one woman who was
you know watching him you know
throughout the
stuff with the tv and also the guy who
was like with mobius in the 1500s or
whatever like even that guy
who i think he might have died at the
end there
but you know i thought even he was like
oh this guy's got a little attitude
speaks french too
you know yes and that's like that's
another thing it's like oh okay
like all these you know tva grunts and
stuff like that but he's like i speak
every language
on the timeline just like you so that's
another thing i'm like okay these
these are more than just grunt soldiers
yeah theoretically
ah good stuff i loved it yeah absolutely
loved it yeah this is
the kind of tonal adventure i've been
waiting for
all right guys well leave your thoughts
down below what did you think of this
first episode
subscribe click that notification bell
hit the like button
of course we'll check out a much
better expert suited individual for the
easter eggs breakdown stuff
and last but not least who's the lucky
michael linden mikhail
i feel like
you know it's funny michael i just feel
sorry for you
[Laughter]
why because i i bet there's a version of
him
that all right here's what i'm gonna do
i'm gonna set you up to do your john
thing of tying it in
okay all right mikhail has wanted bond
to come out
i know he could be available poor mchale
who goes and finds the timeline
yeah or the pandemic never happened oh
my god and then uh
also uh disney plus took forever to get
to his home country yeah of sweden
yeah all right so do it okay so then so
mikhail oh no
you you've been apprehended by the time
variance authority
why because you broke the timeline you
jumped over
to someplace else where bond 22 had
already been released
and on home video you bought all the
copies so that there was a shortage in
the world and then they had to track you
down and you know what's the worst part
is that cosmically it was never supposed
to come out in the first place
so when you get back to the time
variance authority they're going to have
to wipe your memory it'll be like you
never
saw no time to die so mikhail i'm really
sorry about that man
i hope that one of your variants is able
to maybe like see the movie and then
like die right afterwards so that you
just always have that memory
but uh either way thanks for your
support here and for not leaving
the timeline of our patreon because
that's the most
that's even better than no time to die
his
reaction good time to live over here
right time to live
yes time to live all right thank you
mikhail
you get the loki shout out
[Music]
you